[Musique]
évitez de quartier au oui j'appelle 50
points et vous avez connu la bièvre
moment écoulée a découvert quand vous
vous passer celle là la droite locale
rue des alpes à cette impasse de la
photographie qui existe toujours ce
match est un génie
il passait dans la rue censier passaient
ensuite parce qu'on se connaît
nous on pensait la presse qu'autrefois
l'avait lebowski et au sri et laval en
faux films étaient à gagner dans le
pétrole puisse y avoir du pouvoir
vous avez connu le
inondations de la neige au sable en
quelle année 1910 pour janvier depuis
qu'elle a mis elle a été recouverte aux
choix donc être prudent ce moment-là
1910 pourquoi quelqu'un du club et vous
savez pourquoi on l'a recouverte rang de
l'association est
ça sentait mauvais monsieur vous êtes
imprimeurs et vous êtes installée dans
le quartier depuis combien d'années et
de bulles 1937 mais je suis né dans le
6e arrondissement et ai vécu à peu près
depuis 1908 dans le troisième alors vous
avez bien connu la vierge quand elle
courrait à découvert c'est à dire
lorsque j'étais petit que j'étais en
pension je me suis promené avec les
camarades et je les ai vus au du côté de
la poterne des peupliers
je les connais un peu a découvert du
côté du boulevard auguste blanqui qui
vivaient dans le temps et l ancien
voleur l'italie et et après je les ai
vus ils n'ont pas en maraude en mai en
allant
dessiner à la manufacture des gobelins
je les vis dans leur jardin qui se
trouvait nous allons 2
déconstruit je vois que vous avez faites
vous des livres qui retrace toute son
histoire ou et c'est une livre qui
m'avait été donnée par mon beau-père et
qui m'a dit que tout si vous voulez tous
les renseignements sur paris et ses
environs et de châteaudun blanche le
château de la reine loges c'est un vieux
château qui doit dater du temps de
charles 5 je crois il y alla lui je ne
sais pas si c'était lui à ce moment-là
qu'ils aient eu cet accident mais au
lieu au cours d'une fête costumée 1 au
roi s'était enduit de poids il y avait
posé des plumes dessus et face en face
d'une torche il a pris feu et le château
afrique tenu aussi tout un oui mais il
en reste encore une grande partie que
l'on peut voir rue des gobelins
messieurs quel genre de travaux
entreprenez vous dans le quartier nous
construisons l'amex la faculté des
lettres des sciences humaines et vous
avez fait des sondages est ce que vous
avez retrouvé la vierge nous ont fait
les sondages oui nous avons trouvé la
bièvre la vieille bière
qui est d'ailleurs hors d'usagé qui est
fermé aux deux extrémités et qui j'avais
ont actuellement des amas de boue et de
cailloux
m